dix romans également sur le moment où le
ministre le président prend la parole ce
matin
après tout les annonces de cet été sur
la casse sociale sur la casse
territoriale et peut être en campagne le
voir la question des emplois aidés
aujourd'hui c'est aussi mettre la clé
sous la porte de certaines collectivités
les plus modestes des plus petites qui
n'auront pas qu'ils ne pourront pas
rendre à son de service parce
qu'aujourd'hui leurs finances ne
permettent pas d'avoir autre chose qu'un
emplois aidés et nous allons la
différence philosophique fondamentale
sur ce qu'est un emploi était sur ce
qu'est la perception
je rappelle que les employés c'est
permettre à des hommes et des femmes de
revenir vers l'emploi d'avoir un vrai
salaire d'avoir un travail qui va
permettre à des habitants d'avoir un
vrai service et cei pour l'avoir en tête
donc voilà je vous mettais un autre ce
discours électoraliste puisque après
avoir annoncé de mauvaises nouvelles
durant tout l'été et qu'il y a
semble-t-il une sorte de panique au
niveau des remontées du terrain le
premier françois en parlera à beaucoup
mois semble essayer de pallier de
rétropédaler sont vraiment qu'on sache
exactement où ils souhaitent aller
je rappelle pour la petite histoire
chacun se souviendra de la première
conférence territoriale où tout allait
bien se passer
et puis trois jours après des mauvaises
surprises sont arrivés